على مدى سنوات كانت هناك شكوى دائمه من
تعامل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع
مساله تصدير الاسلحه واشنطن تقول ان هناك
معايير اخلاقيه هي التي تتحكم بهذا الامر
في حين يعتبر البعض ان الولايات المتحده
تتخذ احيانا ملف حقوق الانسان كذريعه
لممارسه نوع من انواع الضغط السياسيه على
عملائها مؤخرا اقرت الحكومه الامريكيه
مجموعه من التعديلات الجديده على قوانين
نقل او بيع الاسلحه التقليديه حول هذه
التعديلات وكذلك انعكاسها على مبيعات
الاسلحه الامريكيه وايضا كيفيه تعامل
الشركات الامريكيه معها معنا من واشنطن
السيده فاجو مراديان رئيس تحرير موقع
الدفاع وطيران اولا سيد مراديان اهلا بك
معنا في عسكريتاريا برايك ما هي اهم
التعديلات التي اقرتها الحكومه الامريكيه
على قانون بيع الاسلحه وما هي اهميه هذه
الاجراءات يسرني
[موسيقى]
معكم في هذا البرنامج من جديد بدايه اود
ان اوضح ان هذا ليس قانونا بل هي سياسه
بيع السلاح التقليديه وهي تمثل الاليه
التي تقوم من خلالها الولايات المتحده
كجزء من الاطار القانوني العام وتحدد درجه
المرونه التي تتمتع بها الاداره الامريكيه
لتقرر صفقات بيع السلاح التقليديه التي
يمكن السماح بها او رفضها بدايه هذه
التعديلات ليست بالضروره الجديده بل هي
تضيف صفه رسميه للمنهج الذي تتبعه اداره
بايدن منذ توليها الرئاسه لتؤكد انها
ستدفع بمساله حقوق الانسان عند اجراء
صفقات لبيع السلاح التقليديه والدوله
الوحيده المعفيه من هذه الاجراءات هي كندا
لكن بالنسبه للدول الاخرى فهناك اعتبارات
لحقوق الانسان لكن هناك عنصرا اخر يتم
اقفاله وهو على نفس القدر من الاهميه ان
هناك محدد اخر وهو طبيعه العلاقه بين
الدوله بالصفقه مع كل من الصين وروسيا وقد
تاخرت هذه السياسه قليلا بسبب الحرب
الاوكرانيه لكن في نهايه الامر فان الاطار
العام الذي تحاول ان تستفيد منه الاداره
هو حقوق الانسان كما يجب الانتباه للصيغه
المستخدمه التي تقول انه من المرجح
الموافقه على صفقه بيع سلاح ان لم يكن لها
اثر سلبي محتمل على حقوق الانسان محليا
كما ان الجزء المتعلق بالصين وروسيا مهم
جدا ولابد من اخذه بالاعتبار حيث هناك
تنافس محتدم بين الولايات المتحده وروسيا
ناهيك عن التنافس مع الصين ايضا السيد
روسيا يعني روسيا خلال السنوات الخمسه
الماضيه كان لديها حصه في السوق العالمي
فيما يتعلق بالمبيعات العسكريه تقارب
العشرين بالمئه منذ بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا باتت هذه الحصه يعني تقل شيئا
فشيئا الان مع هذه التعديلات الجديده هل
ستستفيد الشركات الامريكيه هل ستسمح لها
هذه التعديلات بمزيد من الاستفاده من
الحصه الروسيه ام انها ستشكل عائقا امام
هذه الشركات
اعتقد من الاهميه بمكان القاء نظره على
الاسواق العالميه اولا هناك فكره في
واشنطن وفي اماكن اخرى ان السلاح الروسي
لم يكن ادائه جيدا خاصه في اوكرانيا
والقدرات الغربيه اثبتت تفوقها لذا لجات
روسيا للضرب بقسوه لتعويض اي نقص لديها في
القدرات التكنولوجيه نحن نعلم ان هذه حرب
طويله لكن الروس يتعلمون من التجربه وسنرى
سرعتهم في التعلم ومن ناحيه الاسواق
العالميه فان ميزانيه الدفاع الامريكيه
ستزداد لتصل الى نحو 880 مليار دولار
الولايات المتحده والاداره في واشنطن يرون
صفقات بيع السلاح على انها اداه مهمه
للشراكه وطريقه فعاله لدعم شركائنا
وحلفائنا لكن ان نظرنا للمساله من زاويه
الاولويات الامريكيه في الاسواق العالميه
سنجد ان على صناعه تلبيه مطالب والمطالب
القوميه الامريكيه باعاده تعبئه المخزون
الامريكي من السلاح كما نرى اوروبا تشهد
نهضه ضخمه لتطوير قدراتها في اعقاب
العدوان الروسي وهناك منطقه الهادي الهندي
حيث الحلفاء والشركاء يسعون للحصول على
قدرات وكذلك الشرق الاوسط ان كان فيه فرص
فهو السوق العالميه الرابعه وتعد على درجه
من الاهميه
هل الحرب تزيد الفرص لمصنعي سلاحف الغرب
نعم لكن في هذه المرحله المهم هو الطلب
فكل الصناعات الغربيه تتحرك بعجاله لتامين
الذخيره والمركبات العسكريه والمنصات لذلك
سيكون هذا القطاع مثيرا للاهتمام على مدى
السنوات القليله القادمه من حيث معرفه
فائض المخزون الذي يمكن ان يساعد في تلبيه
الطلب على تصدير السلاح وهنا ايضا يمكن ان
نخضع المساله لتحديد الاولويات من حيث من
هو الاكثر للسلاح فهناك دول ما زالت تنتظر
الحصول على القدرات بسبب بعض التحديات في
مجال التزويد الذي زاد تعقيده بعد الحرب
في اوكرانيا
الان على مستوى العالم بات هناك الكثير من
الدول الواعده في مجال الصناعات الدفاعيه
وكذلك هي اكثر انفتاحا على مشاركه
التكنولوجيا بل وحتى تصدير الاسلحه لدول
اخرى لدينا الصين ولدينا كذلك دول اخرى
مثل كوريا الجنوبيه وغيرها برايك هل
التعديلات الجديده فيما يتعلق بهذه
المساله هل راعت هذه المساله وراعت وجود
منافسين للولايات المتحده الان في السوق
العالمي وام انه هذه التعديلات ستشكل عائق
امام الشركات الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
لست متاكدا لكنها تفعل اذ ان اي تعقيد
امام صفقه سلاح من وجهه نظر هذا القطاع
يعد اشكاليا بعض الشيء ومن الناحيه
الثانيه يرى القطاع انه ستكون هناك وفره
في الفرص خاصه في الاسواق المحليه مع
الشركاء والحلفاء ممن ليست لديهم مسائلات
حول حقوق الانسان اعتقد ان اي دوله تشتري
انظمه روسيه وصينيه توجه كذلك رساله
لواشنطن وهي رساله ستهتم بها واشنطن كثيرا
ربما هناك دوله وحيده يمكن ان تحظى
باستثناء هي الهند بسبب اهميتها
الجيوستراتيجيه وهي اكبر دوله في العالم
حاليا وتحظى بثقل يضاه الصين من نواحي عده
رغم استمرارها في شراء السلاح الروسي هناك
ضغط داخل النظام الهندي وخارجه لوقف
التسلح من روسيا لكن الامر المهمه هو ان
المتحده تنظر للمساله بشكل موسع ان كنت
تساعد الاوليجارش الروسي او تحول الاموال
لروسيا او لتجاوز العقوبات عليها اظن ان
هذا يضيف المزيد من التعقيد بالنسبه للدول
التي تود ان تضع لها في كل معسكر قدما
وهذه رساله مهمه لابد من اخذها في
الاعتبار بان الولايات المتحده تنظر للامر
على انها لا تريد ان يستغل نظامها بشكل
ينعكس سلبا عليها وكذلك لا تريد من الدول
التي تزداد تقاربا مع الصين وروسيا ان
تستفيد من القدرات الامريكيه او ان تكون
هذه الدول تساعد دول اخرى تراها امريكا
على انها اشكاليه ومن المثير للاهتمام ان
نرى دول اوروبا تتخذ نهجا مماثلا مع تزايد
قلقهم من روسيا ومن الصين لذلك قد لا يكون
هذا راي واشنطن فقط بل يمكن ان يكون رايا
غربيا موسعا وقد كانت كوريا الجنوبيه
ناجحه جدا بسبب امتلاكها قدرات وفيره لا
يمتلكها مثل قدرات المدفعيه والدبابات
وكذلك القدرات التي عملوا على تطويرها
بذكاء فائق فبالتالي ان الدوله التي
ستستفيد من ذلك بشكل كبير هي كوريا
الجنوبيه
السيد مراديان واشنطن تقول دائما ان
معايير حقوق الانسان هي الاساس برايك هل
ستتاثر الصفقات العسكريه ما بين واشنطن
وتل ابيب بسبب المعايير التي تتحدث عنها
واشنطن خاصه في ظل التقارير الكثيره التي
تتحدث عن الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه لحقوق
الانسان
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان التحدي تاريخي ومعقد فالولايات
المتحده هي الضامن الامني لاسرائيل في
الشرق الاوسط وكذلك الضامن الامني في
الخليج العربي ومناطق اخرى فيما يتعلق
بعلاقه اداره نتنياهو واشنطن فمن السهل
القول انها متوتره ومن المثير ان نراقب
كيف ستتحول العلاقه بسبب الاحباط الذي
يعانيه المجتمع اليهودي الامريكي من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه التي تزداد
تشددا في القدس هذه العلاقه ستواجه تحديات
عديده واعتقد ان كثرا ينظرون لهذه العلاقه
على انها علاقه نفاق لكن هناك عنصرا مهما
في العلاقه الاسرائيليه الامريكيه وهو
منصوص عليه في القانون بان الولايات
المتحده ملزمه قانونيا بمساعده اسرائيل في
المحافظه على تفوقها العسكري على اعدائها
قد يتغير ذلك او يمكن تعليق صفقات التسلح
ان قرر اعضاء الكونجرس التاخير فليست
الاداره وحدها هي التي توافق على الصفقات
بل على العالم ان يدرك ان اعضاء الكونجرس
وخاصه الشيوخ لديهم الصلاحيه لوقف تنفيذ
الصفقات وكانت امريكا قد اخرت نقل بعض
القدرات لاسرائيل على مدى عقود بسبب عدم
رضاها عما كانت تقوم به الحكومه من المثير
للاهتمام ان نرى كيف سيتم تفسير هذه
السياسه في تلك الحاله علي ان اوضح هنا ان
القلق الاميركي يكون في معرفه ان كان سلاح
الامريكي يتم استخدامه في وضعيه خاطئه
اسرائيل من كبريات الدول المصنعه للسلاح
واي سلاح تقوم بتصنيعه مثل اي سلاح تصنعه
الامارات او اي جهه اخرى يمكن استخدام هذه
الاسلحه بحريه طالما كانت هذه الاسلحه لا
تحتوي على اي عنصر امريكي
رئيس تحرير موقع الدفاع وطيران شكرا جزيلا
على وجودك معنا